imagine walking into a convenience store
and behind the counter are packs of
joints stamps with the big tobacco
companies logos this is likely the
future Big Tobacco is flatlining
and marijuana is this new gigantic
market that could spring it back to life
it's estimated that demand for
recreational marijuana could be as big
as 45 billion dollars a year that's
bigger than both wine and chocolate
cigarettes are still a huge ninety
billion dollar market but fewer
Americans are smoking them it's down to
less than 18% of the population and that
figure continues to fall low gas prices
have supported the industry because
people often buy cigarettes when they
refuel their tanks a recent mega merger
is also helping to keep revenue up but
growth is stagnating and the u.s.
cigarette market is now so concentrated
that few large deals remain Altria the
maker of Marlboro and Reynolds which you
may remember for its Joe Camel mascot
together sell almost 80% of cigarettes
in the u.s. so where is the next growth
driver Big Tobacco is investing in new
products like ecigs and vaporizers but
those are still only a tiny portion of
the market and will take a lot of time
and money to scale up which brings us
back to marijuana big tobacco secretly
looked into cannabis as far back as the
1970s and it should again right now
Colorado Washington Oregon Alaska and DC
have legalized weed and all of these
other states in pink have either
decriminalized it and or permitted
medicinal use with ballot measures and
legislation underway states representing
roughly half the population may soon
allow the purchase of weed in some form
right now unsurprisingly Altria tells me
that it has no plans to sell marijuana
based products doing so is still illegal
in the eyes of the US government the
federal government is probably going to
legalize pot it's just a matter of time
and when that happens the opportunity
will be too attractive for big tobacco
to ignore